okay so did you guys meet at all during
filming of this movie a few of us did
yeah yes I was forced into actually
Robert I was gonna say yeah you guys did
but some folks need to be vetted more
than others machine and John Knight met
briefly before and and and we're doing a
dinner we're all getting together at
some point and have we run we've run
into each other a premiere it was cool
you would be whisked to now do me and
flag me anytime there you go it's all
good because when Scarface the squirrel
comes around so Doolittle is a hermit
right yeah um I kind of identify with
that I call myself like the introvert
and extrovert like I have to be an
extrovert at work but I like being a
homebody
do you anybody relate to that one yeah
everybody in agoraphobia or that fear
going out I think sometimes because
we're you know we're out on Front Street
we're being filmed there's 70 people
watching us all that stuff and then you
go back to your home and it's normal
even today like starting press today I
go a little bit like oh I have to get
used to I hire a recruit for people to
be at home with me all the time like
they on display I like to perform I
don't like to be not performance
extroverted so Doolittle's talent as he
talks to animals so I want to go down
the road and I want to find out a talent
that you guys have that we may not know
about
oh great come on and you want to go down
the line starting with John hasn't said
anything yet he's been sitting over here
just cuteness nudist three-piece suit
for for a larger fellow or fellow of
larger stature I can easily blend in and
and maybe even get to an interview with
saying
what might be a talent that that we
haven't seen display there we would say
oh wow I didn't I didn't know hmm that's
a great question Rob thank you I would
have to say my ability to force myself
and be uncomfortable and not be afraid
to fail Wow there you go
okay yo anybody followed that one
amateur ventriloquist let's go let's go
I was gonna say now you got to show him
[Laughter]
my guy with me if you want we could make
this happen
amateurs you got nothing to prove man
thank you
I'll put it out there I can tap dance a
little
by the way YouTube did you go in did you
audition for the bear and the squirrel
or did they say we have an ID this is
what we want you to play yeah they did
yeah well I started out as Fleming the
mouse and then it switched to Kevin the
squirrel really you know something yeah
doesn't just to go on job as Yoshi from
jump and I have to tell you particularly
my missus was just so astonished not
surprised and pleased with not just your
performance but just your general energy
because sometimes doing doing that
voicing or something rather I can find
it can be very confining and if it
doesn't feel free it kind of like uh
come on I got better stuff you said your
your attitude your professionalism and
the fun you brought to the character she
was just like just a game changer Aysen
everybody could just embrace he's a
gentle giant he's he walks in he's
imposing but he really is just a softy
no I thought that was a fun part of it
being able to do it and when you can
play to type and then still be
vulnerable at points that's also pretty
fun to do Robert this is one of the
first times that we've seen you not Iron
Man yeah he sent years the other time I
guess we went in 2014 the judge right so
why was this one the perfect first post
Marvel movie yeah I mean it worked out
that way I'm not quite as I'm not a big
strategy guy and I think I've learned a
lot that you know we want to make God
laugh tell him your plans and sometimes
things just come along and it felt just
like a nice shift and it turns out it
was just a beautiful experience it was
difficult for sure but it's a beautiful
experience making this project just
because the subject matter is so it's
it's really contemplatively makes me
think about things that are really
relevant and then of course it's fun and
commercial and kids alike it you know
I'm most of the Marvel movies that was
doing all these kids you know but it's
pg-13 for a reason whereas I feel like
this is a bit of a bigger net we're
draggin well now when we drag you back
into because Black Widow is coming out
so yes a rumor is that we may see Tony
Stark in some form right when we buckle
up I mean it would be nice if they
notified me warned is forearmed
they can do anything now this could be a
deep fake interview forward he's good by
the way
this was kind of like in your lane too
because you have so many animals right
you felt like an alpaca and cows yep
pigs and all of that goats
yep yeah so where did your love of
animal
come from we just happened to get this
property that had been on the market
nobody else really wanted it and it was
it was an old dog and horse rescue and
so there's a lot of there was a lot of
places where animals could be looked for
it and looked after and cared for and
then over time sometimes it would be a
gift like someone gave us a couple votes
once and then next thing you know
[Laughter]
somebody goes well then did you wake in
the morning to go surprise and then you
go out one of the little paddock so
there's a couple goats in there nobody
goes sheep for in this morning
can I just me my mom just went to South
Africa and our guide he got goats for
his his wife swap yeah that was part of
her dowry who has pets I used to have
two Turtles that I don't have them
anymore
really nope it is the turtle story like
I can tell you I just you know I gave
him away this year so yeah yeah okay
John I want to ask you because we saw
your you and Justin Bieber the social
media posts going yeah I know you're a
BTS guy yeah are you also a believer oh
sure you are
yeah don't kid trying to find his way
through life he's got all sorts of crazy
stuff just kind of figured out this guy
this guy right and I think he wants to
fight me at WrestleMania I think awesome
would you be so brief could we make even
the littlest thing like that happen you
and Bieber Bieber you know where to find
me and by the way um I laughed more than
the kids around me in this movie I
laughed out loud like well I was like oh
people were looking like really girls
like you're grown when I was a kid the
cartoons were made for adults to be able
to say that was witty and highbrow
and for the kids to be entertained and
then I feel like that whole genre of
entertainment went away for a generation
you know and I want to thank y'all for
bringing it back see yes I didn't know I
needed this people together but I'm glad
I got it yeah
[Music]